crash bandicoot 4 it's about time is the
latest game to get a brand new
next generation upgrade this one is
pretty straightforward you're going to
see some faster loading times on the ps5
but otherwise it looks visually the same
except
now it runs at up to a native 4k it may
not seem like much of a difference at
first glance but when you compare them
side by side
the ps5 version is notably sharper if
you want to fully appreciate this
difference make sure to view this video
in 4k you also might notice some slight
tweaks to color and
lighting if you enjoyed this video make
sure to give us a like and subscribe so
we can keep making
more comparisons like this one enjoy
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
crash bandicoot at last
i the great neocortex have you right
where i want you
and now the final blow
hush simpleton
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guys
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
hmm
hang on guys i'm coming
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much wait donna
but you're different
you're not from our universe
[Music]
it's good to see you guys it's been a
long time for me
we lost touch in your universe too huh
yeah
you could say that what did we like
die or something what no nope no but no
definitely not so how are things in your
dimension
the usual a bunch of evil scientists
attempting interdimensional domination
huh so uh
what you're collecting crystals gems
masks oh fun well good luck with that
wait you're not coming sorry i fly solo
[Music]
but i'll i'll lend a hand where i can in
fact
i already have
[Music]
[Music]
you